We finished encoding our states
in the BURLAP domain, so
now let's add actions
to the domain as well.
To add actions to domain
objects we generate,
we can use a method built into the
GraphDefinedDomain class, setTransition.
This method is used to define
both the set of actions and
the transition function for the MDP.
The first argument is an int
giving the ID of the state
S we are transitioning from.
The second argument is also an int,
giving the ID the action
we are defining.
I'll talk about that
more in just a second.
The third argument is an int
giving the ID of the state
T we are transitioning into.
And the fourth argument is a double,
giving the probability of transitioning
to state T upon taking this action.
Note that many different actions
coming out of the same state can have
the same ID.
But the probabilities of the actions
with the same ID leaving
a given state must add up to one.
Looking at our state diagram again,
if we want to define the action a,
taking us from state 0 to state 1,
we can call setTransition
with the arguments 0 for
the ID of the state we are leaving.
0, since this is the first action
we're defining from state 0.
1, which is the ID of the state
we are transitioning into.
And 1, and I'm adding a decimal point
to denote that this is a double.
Since this is a deterministic action,
with probability 1 we
will always enter state 1 by
taking action 0 from state 0.
To define action b, we call
setTransition with the arguments,
0, again because we are leaving state 0.
1, since this is going to
be action 1 from state 0.
2, which is the ID of
the state we are entering.
And 1., since again,
this is a deterministic action.
With probability 1, this action
will always take us from S0 to S2.
Similarly, action c will be defined by
calling setTransition with arguments 0,
2, since this is action 2
coming out from state 0.
3 for
the ID of the state we're entering, and
1, since this is a deterministic action.
Now let's put this into our code.
Notice that I am casting this.dg,
which is our DomainGenerator object,
to a GraphDefinedDomain
before calling setTransition.
This is needed because
setTransition is not defined for
the DomainGenerator class.
Another point to notice is that
we are defining all of these
actions before we call
this.dg.generateDomain.
We're calling the setTransition
functions first
because it tells the GraphDefinedDomain
object to include these transitions
in its blueprint when it
generates a new domain object.
Calling generateDomain first would
create a domain with six states but
no transitions, as I found out myself
as I was learning to use BURLAP.